now we understand that there's been some
controversy from Muslim organizations
that are trying to to ban the film
yeah that's see it's I don't know
because this phone is probably the most
muscle and friendly film I have seen in
recent times it's not not talking about
I have made I've seen and I'm known to
be a man with equipoise I'm not given to
lean to the left or right
I have my own standpoint and I've been
very clear I'm not a politician I have
never gone into the politics of the
situation but I think I have an ethical
duty to take care of my society and I
have a voice which deservingly or not is
amplified by the work that I do so I'm
very careful in saying what I I say I
would never do a film it's not for the
lack of it you can't make an animal
house kind of funny story about religion
or in America maybe a Monty Python Life
of Brian may not work well in India and
I'm aware of that and my thing is I love
my people and India has seen a lot of
Hindu Muslim differences and suffered
because of that and I grieve that
tragedy very much I think both the
countries should have stayed as one we
became three instead and I regret it but
Who am I I wasn't even born when the
decision were made but I so I'm very
conscious when I make a film not to hurt
a larger sentiment or create a sensation
through saying something nasty but it's
the duty of the filmmaker to remind
what's happening like you make a
Mississippi Burning
you're not taking the the American
African side or the white supremacist
side you're just stating the fact and
say this is what we wear let's not
become it again ever
it's it's a kind of record that you're
trying to create and we should root is
not even that it's it's not a social
statement film it it's a thriller which
is realistic it's thrilling it's fast
it's about espionage but it's it's got
its own texture its truth and beauty
it's not a documentary it's not like
Bigelow's phone but the grim truth it's
it's it's around the same area same team
don't you think in banning it it only
makes things bigger I think so I think
they have done because my in one state
in India we have five hundred theaters
my phone was playing in five hundred
theaters and those theaters have already
booked out for a week and a half all of
them so but there probably that's what
is but you can't because my feeling is
that the central board of censors
they've sat on the film and they had
representatives from the Muslim
community and various other communities
and they have watched the full and
thought over it asked me questions and
they've left it intact
nothing was removed from the film except
that when we wanted a parenting guidance
kind of certificate that's also for
business more than anything else because
parenting guide and adult films are
taxed more very strange funny thing in
in my state but they are taxed more so
we're a bit wary of walking into that
territory so I have to ask for a PG
rating not an hour as you call it so
we got it and without any damage at all
to the phone nor of the contact and once
that is done you can't have small groups
making noises and this is happening in
South Indian it's a it's a group of
something in Muslims who came and I'm
they're my people
I mean I'll have to be kind to them I
may not have a religion but I have love
for people
you